well our next talk this afternoon is by
Bob Murphy from CMU and from the sound
of it you could tell us a little bit
about active learning in a different
context where the coracle if you will
where the source of our information
isn't human expert or crowd of humans by
experiments and I think this is a really
exciting area for active okay so thanks
very much for the opportunity to talk to
you so of course nowadays all we hear
about is big data though all the
opportunities machine learning and
everything well I'm here to talk to you
about a problem that is the is
completely the opposite of that even
though you're hearing all this about bio
big data and there's you know so much
data coming and there's so much data
available
the problem is in biology that we have
nowhere near the data that we need and
it is sort of the quintessential example
of where we need active learning and we
just try to motivate that a little bit
more in terms of some a little bit of
biology and medicine diseases are as we
know extremely meant can many of them
are quite complex can be affected by
many variables we you know each have
different genomes that affects things
the effects of drugs can be different
depending on what your genome is
depending on the patient depending on
the history to patient and so on so if
you try to imagine a model that you
would build that would say what dose
even let alone what drug should I give
to this patient based on all these other
variables I would have to measure a huge
matrix of all of those variables in
order to build a model to tell me what
what to do that
for that and in addition to that in the
drug development space the biggest
problem in drug develop is not finding
drugs that do what we need them to
although that's a important problem it's
finding drugs that do it we need them to
do that
do other stuff alright and so that means
as we'll see in a minute exploring a
very large space of what effect each
drug would have on many different things
in the body rather than just on the one
thing that you're in that you're
interested in so that's also a large
space in all of biological research it
turns out that the first thing there is
is something that I never imagined was
going to be true when I was when I was a
kid you know deciding I wanted to be a
biologist right we thought that you
would learn the book that that I read
that that convinced me to be a bee start
out as a biologist it was called the
genetic code code rules right you learn
the rules well sorry
turns out there are any rules already
didn't even know genetic code it turns
out at least not a fixed one and so what
that means is we're in a space of
biological systems that are complex
systems no rules all that we can really
do is build empirical models of all of
this stuff which includes the fact that
we have thousand tens of thousands of
proteins and genes and we have hundreds
of cell types and you know we have all
of this is all interacting it's it's
it's huge so let's try to take a piece
of that and let's take a piece of that
where we're gonna try to learn for some
system a matrix or tensor that describes
the responses of the system as a
function of different sets of variables
and what I'm going to mean by that and
we're just going to stick with this is a
motivating example but we can change the
variables as we wish
does let's think of the case where we
have many possible drugs
so that's variable number one and we
have many possible targets
that's variable number two okay now we
can add three and four and five as we
want in terms of tissues cell types
patients genotypes anything we want but
we're gonna just stick
with that for right now just to try to
go forward all right and obviously we
want to do that without doing all
possible experiments because the order
of the number of drugs is in the
millions the number of targets that
drugs can have in cells is at least
10,000 probably more like a hundred
thousand and so we're not gonna be able
to do to all those experiments so all
right active learning now let's contrast
what we're we're going to what the way
things are done now what happens now is
that we pick a particular target you
know some protein important in cancer
and we try to find a drug that blocks
that that target so we do a screen for a
lot of different drugs for that target
and there's even some active learning
work to try to reduce the amount the
amount of experiments you have to do for
that but the problem is I said earlier
that's not really what we're trying to
do we didn't learn anything from protein
one that helps us with protein okay and
we need to learn the whole matrix okay
and so people have thought of this
problem from two perspectives one from a
perspective of learning you know doing a
matrix factorization type of study and
analysis where you try to take whatever
you have and try to build a model from
that or from it from a perspective that
we just want to take data on those drugs
we know already and we'll just try to
use that to predict entirely the
behavior of other drugs that we haven't
measured without doing any experiments
so those are the sodas in the two
extremes neither of those are really
satisfactory and so what we want to do
in sort of thinking about what kind of
active learning problem is this it's to
think about these can these
considerations so the first is that
unlike almost all the active learning
examples that you will see in this space
we have no unlabeled data right so there
is no data that we just need to know the
label of there's there's nothing right
all we have is
the variables that you know all the
different drugs I could have and all the
different targets I could have I know
what they are but I don't have any data
even I don't have anything all other
than the response that I measure of one
of those targets to one of those drugs
but I have to do an experiment to get
that response so there's no it's not
like the case of lay on unlabeled
documents or something okay
and we are typically starting with very
little data and when we start with
little data I'm sorry when we who we
consider how much data is missing if
only a little bit of data is missing
okay fine we do some matrix completion
and you know we predict whatever it's
not missing and we're gonna be probably
be okay
and in the case that I mentioned where
we have data a lot of data all the data
on some drugs and not for other drugs
then you know we do some kind of
factorization and we say okay we're
going to predict for the new ones that's
been done reasonably well but it turns
out that the real case that we're that
that is important is that most of the
data or all of the data is missing okay
and we have notes so we have no data we
witch and end so we're starting
basically from nothing okay or from very
little now in that case we might still
have some information to try to make
predictions which would be features of
the drugs or the targets okay that is
measures of for example the chemical
similarity between the drugs or measures
of how similar the pathways are the two
different targets are within the cell
now whether or not they affect similar
similar behaviors or something like that
right
so maybe we do maybe we don't all right
one of the problems is even when we do
we don't necessarily know how good they
are Yeah right so that's another another
whole issue and then the other thing we
need to consider is what is it that we
are trying to predict right you know all
of the active learning that's been done
very
of it that there's been done biology it
has been done where we're trying to
predict basically a binary value and if
sometimes a real value okay but it turns
out that for many responses we can't
think of it in those terms that is
there's not a single axis over which the
response occurs so that I can take a
drug and you know it might affect my
heart rate in one patient but if it
affect my you know clearance rate for
other drugs and another patient those
are two totally different effects so
what I'm what I want to look at there is
the class of the response as well as
potentially some magnitude but mostly
I'm thinking in terms of the class of
response you know does it affect my
kidneys yes or no does it affect my
heart yes or no does it affect you know
the transport of some-some protein in
the cell so that's to just frame the
where we are with the problem okay so
the other thing that we're facing and
you know we've had a number of talks
about active learning ready that almost
all the work on active learning there
are some exceptions um is done to sort
of test an approach using retrospective
studies where you already have the data
available and you even can cheat a
little bit and say well based on what I
know about the data that I have
available I can it meets the assumptions
that I'm making in order to try to build
my model yes
there can be different costs for what
we're going to talk about today they're
all going to be fixed costs fixed costs
but that's because we're it's even bad
enough to deal with that setting right
but absolutely we are going to have to
deal with the the the cost sensitive
active learning and also the Oracle
accuracy problem so what we were talking
about just a minute ago although again
without knowing what the answers to
those are yes this kind of experiment is
it true that you do one cell at a time
very active learning or do you you know
get muffled sounds in a row yeah yep so
you can do either most I mean one of the
things it's kind of an interesting what
the response that biologists in general
have had to this problem enlarged is to
say oh we can't do one experiment at a
time and it get anywhere let's do a
thousand experiments at a time okay like
that's gonna help when you're talking
about you know quadrillions or whatever
you know let's just do a thousand at a
time it will get what get there faster
but we'll all be dead anyway right and
so the answer is that we have equipment
that can do efficiently more
economically sets of experiments and so
we do want batch wise in general want
that twice active learning okay
now so as I was saying most of the work
that's been done has been done with
retrospective studies there are lots of
problems with that one of the problems
is that we could be cheating without
even thinking we're treating by making
running the same analysis many times
until we get the thing we're looking for
and and also checking that it has the
meets the assumptions that we've made
but but also most of the work that's
been done has been done with small such
sets because that's all that has
typically been available so here's some
examples of databases of datasets that
have been used and you can see that you
know the number these there this is the
number of drugs and the number of
targets there they're small
compared to the size of the space we're
interested in by the way there's also an
interesting phenomenon here which is and
we'll get back to this that the question
of how many of the combinations actually
show a response right whether responses
are frequent or not and many of these
the responses are quite frequent but its
data sets have been studied so far now
so here's the first result we took a
look at these data sets and we did
pretty standard uncertainty based active
learning starting from nothing and
building a model that'll talk to you
about in a minute
the and showed actually I'm sorry this
was done with a basic matrix
factorization method but then with
uncertainty sampling under that and this
is doing random learning random choice
and this is doing active learning and
the point is that all than all of these
data sets where they had previously been
only analyzed in a framework of give me
80% of the data and I'll try to then
predict the remaining 20% we were able
to show that these were very good
candidates for active learning that's
what you could do do well in terms of
building models quickly on this data and
that just summarized here if we take
previous results on taking 80% of
learning a model for 20% and instead we
do active learning up to 80% we get much
better accuracy so okay but now we're
gonna move yes response that's like the
number of non-zeros in the matrix yes
exactly
yeah typically that number is small they
are typically sparse yeah typically but
those data sets are not OK in in the
real world their smarts but in those
they're not so ok so then now we we were
trying to then think about trying to
extend this to the something closer to
the real problem and of course part of
the problem is what what data do we have
it turns out there's a database called
pubchem and there we created a data
subset of that data which has
many more targets and many more
compounds okay however not all the
experiments had been done there was a
lot of missing data from it but there
were features chemical features
similarities chemical similarity
features to to use to measure
similarities between drugs and targets
between drugs and between targets okay
so what we did then is compared oh okay
so here's the problem almost all of
current matrix factorization type
approaches don't work anything this big
at least but not not only computers we
have access to and and so basically you
can't do most of the things that have
been done before on datasets this big
okay or you can't do it practically and
so what we looked at then was to
tackling that problem a problem or we
did not have to construct the entire
matrix and you know do do operations on
the entire matrix but instead just did
something very simple which is to do
given the features for each of the drugs
make a lasso model to predict the target
and vice versa
given all the features of the targets
predict responses to each individual
drug and so we have a whole bunch of row
predictors and a whole bunch of column
predictors and we just average the
results at each point okay very very
simple that but that's just as the
driver for the active learning that's
that's the whole point because the yeah
okay so what we then did is compared
random choice of experiments and this is
number of hits that were found in that
spot these sparse hits or percentage of
the discoveries and that's the random
and this is the way that drug developers
would have done this type of problem in
the past which is to build what's called
a queue so our model quantitative
structure-activity relationship which is
a model for each drug for each target
sorry for each target alone and then
this was and so this is doing
active learning with just that kind of
model for just the targets this is doing
it with the combined model and what what
you can see here is that we're starting
to get the kind of results we want which
is we got 57% of the hits in this sparse
matrix it's point oo 1% of hits with two
and a half percent of the matrix
experiments being done so that's
starting to be encouraging in terms of
whether or not this is going to pan out
now of course as I mentioned these this
was based on having features to be able
to make predictions even before we
started that turns out too often not be
true and what are we so what do we do if
we don't have features or they're not
reliable and also that was all done with
either binary or real valued outputs
what do we do if the outputs are
multi-dimensional so an example of that
is much closer to the reality in the
experimental work is that we do an
experiment by taking some cells adding a
drug taking an image of the cells and
then try to figure out what happened
right and so what it means is that we're
now in the space where any phenotype is
possible right and we don't know in
advance what the phenotypes are so we
don't we don't have anything so what we
did within this scenario was to say okay
we're going to do some very
straightforward things we're going to
we're going to measure features not of
the drugs and targets but of the image
and then make a representation of the
possible phenotypes shown so we're gonna
have image features like texture
features you know whatever whatever you
want and then we'll have cloth clusters
of phenotypes that are going to be
responses that are similar to different
drugs that show the same response yes
though the images are of cells that are
expressing a target treated with a drug
so that what's going to happen is the
target is going to change when you add
the drug we're gonna make an implicit
clump clustering assumption okay but
it's gonna be done it just turns out we
need to do that on the fly all right so
we're gonna we're gonna keep clustering
because we we may have in the last round
of experiments we may have learned a new
a neutrino type so we have we
continuously doing that okay so so the
point is we're gonna cluster the image
phenotypes yes guys we don't have any
images until we do an experiment an
experiment consists of exposing a target
to a particular drug interacts or
combined with this protein because we
know what those chemical structures are
is that part of it can be on those
simulations are expensive and not
particularly revealing or you know
they're very good for cases where you
have a lot of where you have a lot of
knowledge about that particular protein
you know many different structures of it
and so on so it so there are many cases
where that's not very useful measure of
similarity or relationship among
different yes and that was the previous
setting we were talking about where we
did have such features we're now in the
setting where we don't have that all we
have is the images we're gonna make our
own we're using the same word where's
their own features now of the images in
order to decide what phenotype is being
displayed okay so um so now we're you
know we're in a space where the thing we
would normally think of doing then is to
do some kind of matrix factorization on
the
phenotypes and so we're gonna do a you
know I see to the you know pants type
approach to doing that which I'm going
to tell you about which is to say okay
each experiment we're going to assign a
phenotype by clustering which is a color
and then we're gonna try to group the
drugs by which drugs are not provably
dissimilar okay so we're gonna group all
the drugs that are potentially the same
so I'm going to take the smallest set of
of groups that are consistent with
what's known okay and then we do the
same thing for well I did that for
targets the same thing for drugs okay
and then the idea of course is that we
can predict the phenotypes for everybody
now based on just assuming that if
you're a member of this club of this
group of drugs you're gonna have the
same phenotypes that any other member of
that group has displayed okay and that
gives us a predictive model okay
so for anything where we at least have
some measurements we can do a predictive
model of of the responses okay so how do
we use that in active learning alright
so this is also touching on things we've
heard the last two days on what we're
going to do is we're going to say which
experiments explicitly test the
assignment of a drug to a group okay so
in other words were going to try to
break the factor is this this implicit
factorization we've done by grouping the
drugs okay and we're also going to take
into account if we were to falsify one
of those assignments how many other
things would we have learned how many
other things would have been falsified
how many overall predictions would have
been falsified so this is you know along
the theme that's frequent in active
learning of of trying to get some sort
of mutual information and measurement
you know or well you know some way of
trying to measure the impact of doing an
experiment on future models okay but
without having the ability to do an
explicit calculation of all of that okay
all right so then we pick about your
experiments we do the experiments okay
now using that approach we're going to
now try to do this prospectively okay so
we set up an automated robot that can
add drugs to cells and we set up an
automated microscope that can take
pictures of cells and we set up computer
pipelines to calculate all the image
features and count cluster the cluster
the resulting features assign phenotypes
build the model pick the set you know
we're picking a hitting set of the the
experiments that we think maximize you
know the criteria that we just talked
about and then we're gonna run that and
when you just run it and we're not gonna
let not get to get in the way all right
so we're good so we're gonna actually
have the computer decide which
experiments to do next the robots do the
experiments give that data back computer
decides on the next faction we just do
that okay
so here's this example of the space so
these are a bunch of different tagged
proteins so what I mean by tag is that
we can see a specific protein in green
when we take a picture on the microscope
and that tagged protein is changing so
these are 48 different tagged proteins
that are going to be our universe of
proteins and we're also going to have 48
drugs and we're gonna try to learn the
effect of those 48 drugs on those 48
targets where we know nothing about
either the drugs or the targets on their
effects of each other we know if nothing
starting out alright so there's our
space but the problem is since we don't
know anything about this we don't have
any way of knowing whether anything's
right yes
you touched on this but I'm trying to
figure it so where are you getting where
you either getting or growing the image
features that you're clustering so the
image that's the thing that my group has
been doing for a long time which is
automating analysis of this type of
images so we have a lot of experience
with feature image features to analyze
the phenotypes that are being displayed
by the cells okay so there are things
like texture measures you know distances
between things and so on so we have a
lot we have a presume that you have a
good it's not actually a classifier
because we don't have classes but it's
an unsupervised feature set yep we have
that all right so we don't have but we
don't know what the right answer is so
we can do all this work we get some
model at the end but we have any idea of
whether that models right so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna duplicate all
the drugs and all the targets but not
tell the computer that so we're going to
tell the computer there are 96 drugs and
96 sorry gets but there actually are
only 48 and when it asks for one and 27
we're gonna give it the same drug or the
same target so we know which of the
duplicates but it doesn't okay so it's
dealing with a 96 by 96 base that
actually has is 48 by 48 whoops okay
okay so we start out with all of the
drugs we just do the first round we give
it to start all the drugs for all one of
the drug all of the drugs for we start
out with the no drug case for all of the
targets where we don't add anything
that's drug one or actually drove
whatever it is 36 all right so we start
out by that and then it starts building
its model its initial model by the way
is that nobody has an effect right but I
know the phenotype of all the targets
but I don't know what and everybody has
no effect and it starts to choosing
experiments and now when we stop and we
stop interestingly because we ran into
money alright we only had a certain
budget for this we ran on the money we
stopped and have when we had done that
we had sample 28 percent of the possible
experiments and that represented 72
percent of the drug target combinations
when you take into account the
duplication right so we cuz we as long
as we'd sample one from every quad we
dealt with that one so then we did the
remaining unique combinations after the
fact so we do the last round where we
just filled out the 48 by 48 space okay
now here's a key thing what we're gonna
do is we're gonna ask at each round of
active learning how good was the model
but we can't compare the predictions
because they're clustering dependent so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna ask
how close was the predicted phenotype to
the actual phenotype okay and that in in
the feature space and that's gonna be
our measure of the accuracy okay so here
is let's get this running
here's a movie in which the
start oh it started okay purple means
I'm wrong
green means I'm right the models right
and white means we've actually done that
experiment and what you can see is as
you'd expect as we're going along in the
number of experiments on the bottom we
get more white and the thing starts
turning green okay yes
okay so one answer to that question is
do all 48 by 48 right all right if
knowing that at the end what the
phenotypes are what could we have
clustered in what could we have gotten -
you mean not how many experiments who
would take to get to that but what would
if I just guess the absolute right
experiments if I knew the right
experiments it's still pretty high it's
still pretty high because there's not a
lot of there's not a lot of similarity
outside of the similarity we added by
duplicating yes so what that means is
those are drugs that the model didn't
learn well and the reason is it turns
out there are cases where the response
of the cells is very variable okay so in
the number of experiments that we did
you know the number of images we
collected per experiment the phenotype
itself was not robust so that when we
did the same experiment twice we got two
different apparent phenotypes and
therefore of course the model got
confused
well it's it's I mean right in this case
we are not we did not add in do more
experiments until you get you know a
more robust s error right we just had a
fixed number of experiments that would
certainly be like that's Reb to right
okay so what is the overall picture here
on after twenty eight percent of the
experiments the model is 92 percent
accurate yes just calculations so 48
squared is like 2500 or something and
then in the previous graph you were
showing many more experiments and yet
there were like the the graph like the
matrix wasn't white right
so the Express that space is 90 2009 200
right 96 by 96 and because we duplicated
everything but it doesn't know that all
right so 1920 28 percent of the
experiments 92% correct model and random
choice of experiments would have gotten
us about 40% less accuracy and by the
way all almost all of that performance
came from it figuring out quickly the
duplication structure which of course is
exactly what we're hoping in the real
world that it's got to find things that
are similar right there's no free lunch
the only way it's gonna be able to do
that is to find things that are similar
ok so last thing I'm gonna just talk
about then so that I this by the way is
the first example of active learning in
biology where we didn't know ahead of
time what the phenotypes were we didn't
know anything okay so it's the
open-ended real-world case that we're
going into some space and we're just
gonna start doing experiments to try to
get answers but in that real-world theme
one of the real issues is how do white
when do I know to stop right assuming I
still have money should I stop and save
some of that money
and this is I mean there's work on this
problem it's surprisingly not talked
about very often and that's probably
because so much active learning work is
done retrospectively where you know the
final full model and so you can
calculate the accuracy and you can do
everything right so but in the real
world of course the whole point is to
avoid doing though all the experiments
and you don't have an estimate of the
overall accuracy other than what you get
from what data you have all right so we
need a stopping criteria stopping role
or something typically in the past those
that there's been proposals for a single
criterion like you know how consistent
are the predictions you know or
something like that okay
and we just decided to try a different
approach to that that I'm going to talk
to talk to you about and they're ready
to do that we're going to talk about is
the idea that we can characterize an
experimental space all right and we're
gonna characterize or parameterize an
experimental space using in our case two
parameters which are the sparseness of
the interaction that is how often does a
target respond to a drug write an
arbitrary target despondent arbitrary
drug what what's the probability that it
will affect it and how similar the drugs
or the targets are to each other right
so if if you get a uniqueness of a
hundred percent that means there no
there are no factors it's full rank you
know in which cases go home right but
those are going to be our that's our
impair our theoretical description of
the experimental space I'm not going to
defend that one over others but the idea
is I'm going to create some
parameterization of the experimental
space by the way there's another hidden
parameter in here which is the
phenotypes
how many phenotypes there are all right
but we're not going to worry about that
right now
so what we did is a whole bunch of
experiments using algorithm I talked
just talk
about before this no features you know
the empirical clustering and and and
factoring and this shows the improvement
of active learning over random depending
on the responsiveness in the uniqueness
and as you expect if you're in the
unique case it's hopeless
right you're getting no improvement and
if you're in the case where there are
very very few responses you're the
needle and the haystack case and you're
not going to do too much better than oh
you know you may be lucky but in the big
swath of this we're getting significant
improvement of course with active
learning because there is something to
learn there's some there's some
factorization to learn there's some
grouping to learn and and you have
enough phenotypes of currying that you
find them because you have to find so
many types in order to be able to group
the the compounds the drugs okay so
assuming we have some such
parameterization what we're gonna do is
we're gonna define a set of features of
an active learning trajectory okay so if
we do a simulated by the way those all
of these were simulated results okay
this is we presuppose we have a model of
this uniqueness this responsiveness
synthesized data for that then do active
learning on that data and see how well
we did compared to random yes and so so
this so this we can do we can do the
simulations whatever the
parameterization of the space is we can
subdivide it and do simulations for the
whole space or a big portion of it and
what we're going to do then is for each
of those active learning curves each of
those learning curves we're going to
calculate features of the curve like how
did the consistency change from step to
step you
how many things that I find so far and
so on and so forth all right there's a
whole bunch of them but then what we're
gonna do is learn a regresar from those
features to the accuracy because we know
the correct accuracy because it
simulated data so we're gonna then do is
to say if this is a fair
parameterization of the space then I
will have a predictor of accuracy for
experiments drawn from that space okay
and and so that's what that's what these
results are this is showing the correct
accuracy versus the predicted accuracy
and this is the probability that the
real accuracy is higher than my
predicted accuracy so this is you know
I'm estimating a lower limit for the
accuracy and for this whole space here I
can do that right it's only when I get
all the way up to like 95% saying that
the accuracy is actually higher than 95%
of course it's starting to starting the
probably no that's dropping off okay so
in the range that we probably care about
ninety to nineteen eighty ninety percent
accuracy I can get at least for these
experiments very accurate prediction
does that make sense okay and so we then
we did that for retrospective data that
we talked about earlier all right
so this is the actual learning curve and
this is our estimator which is being
conservative saying you know all right I
think this is the correct accuracy all
right and so it works for all you know
for each of these cases that we get and
if we do the same thing we did before
now I've changed this column this is not
doing 80 percent training 20 percent
testing this is deciding to stop after
you know 50 or 30 or whatever percent of
the experiments because I think I'm done
all right and I can get a comparable
accuracy to having just done the 80
percent by stopping automatically with
with that rule okay so the idea there is
just that because in the real world
cases where we know so little about what
we're we're we're working in these are
potential tricks or tools that we can
use to try to adapt ourselves to that
space by using this idea of simulating
experimental spaces okay so yeah so in
this simulated world when you kind of
try to design this prediction by looking
at are you complicit lessor taking a
uniform average over that space is that
so what's happening is each simulated
active learning experiment gets a set of
features and they get thrown into the
regressor and it just you know tries to
estimate an accuracy for that right well
they get associated with an actual
accuracy that ended up with being
equally ready to throw name we can
obviously do better than that but that's
that's the start okay now and one of the
so that the the the big factors there
are being able to have some such
parameterization and then you know we
run it on the date on you know for the
data that is matched to whatever space
we're actually gonna try to work okay so
conclusions we have some results on
active learning both in turn from
retrospective in assets and for this
perspective they had a set where we're
starting from very little which is the
which is the real range that were that
were that were interested in biology
done this in terms of the first real use
of this two to four unknown phenotypes
and we've talked to you about this idea
for trying to estimate accuracy
empirically okay so these are the people
that did most of the work and people
that funded it and I'll stop there and
thank you very much
[Applause]
we used up all the questions predicting
you know unexpected adverse interactions
is much more important than the vast
majority of zeros in the matrix yeah so
it's a great question I it for interest
of time I flipped around between
accuracy and area to the curve you know
which takes that into account right so
in other words in some of those I was
measuring AUC anyway and some are
unexpected and therefore much more
important to catch so okay so we have a
long conversation about my philosophy to
computational biology which is most of
what I learned when I was a PhD student
at Caltech and biology 40 years ago is
wrong okay so expected not expected you
know not really important not really
important concepts to me okay in that
there I mean you know I just found out
about one that had this was discovered a
couple years ago that I didn't even know
about which is that you can make
proteins without ribosomes right I mean
the the whole idea was supposed to be
there DNA makes RNA makes protein and
protein is made by ribosomes for RNA
well you're going to skip the ribosomes
and you can do it by this totally other
system that nobody knew about for you
know decades right so it's alright so I
think that's the answer to your question
but I certainly could put in if I wanted
to you know well I already know these
are you know major interactors and so
I'm gonna you know I have to put more
weight on that or so I could try to get
it yeah okay great
all right time for a break
[Applause]